[Music]
foreign
ews I'm your host Brian jordison and
this is
the news a famous female podcaster has
admitted that she likes to check a man's
bank balance on the first date I'm not
joking I have asked the last three dudes
I've dated for their bank account info
on the first date like the login yeah
can't even just pretend like this is a
thing like I like you and you like me
imagine you're on a first date you're
asking up you know what you're
interested in what kind of music do you
like what kind of movies do you watch
she's like how many [__] zeros are in
that bank account [__] check please
this guy I met like last month and he's
younger desperate he's 27 and has that
much in his account yes I screenshotted
it and sent it to myself Jesus Christ do
you think that's crazy or no
she's literally yes that's one way to
cut out all the [__] of I'm actually
a nice person do you know what I mean
just get straight to the point I'm a
gold digging [__] so you're disturbed
by the number you just saw yeah I'm like
man they told about a 27 year old large
bank balance here by the way and
laughing about it you went on a date
with them
it's a lot but like it's Sophia [__]
freaking
it's not supposed to impress us yeah
well done I don't think it's weird to
ask for that kind of information on a
first date that's because you're [__]
crazy no but that's the thing is I don't
judge people's actions I look at the
intention behind it
he's trying to make this all right I
like it what was your intention well to
make sure that he has much money as
humanly possible so that I can take it
off oh well then it's fine so like why
do you ask for that because I only want
to date a wealthy guy that has money
bingo oh the fact that the guy even gave
you the bank balance it makes him a
[__] by the way but you're not a part
of the problem bro you need you need to
have higher self-esteem and stop letting
women treat you like this because this
is a joke actually I fully support all
sugar babies around the world yes yes
because if there's something that is in
danger right now it's the sugar babies
we do have to worry about them don't we
God bless these little come dumpsters
who want all of your money but I think
you know I have a job I'm very
successful I'm a podcaster too it's not
a job you just sit on a couch and chat
[__] anyone can do it I'm very
successful so I think I have everything
right to be like hi are we on the same
level or am I wasting my time that's
your biggest mistake you having money
does not entitle you to getting a man
with money what is a man with loads of
money give a [__] about what's in your
bank account for if he's already [__]
loaded himself he doesn't need your
money to look after him if anything if
you're earning all this cash it's more
of a headache we gotta keep up with you
if you talk out a turn the worst you
give it that whole [__] I don't need
you I've got my own money no man wants
to hear that it makes no difference
whether to a man whether you work in
McDonald's or you're a podcaster or
you're working at a bank we don't care
men want nice women who speak to them
nicely who are pretty it's not rocket
science especially if they're under 5
10. like if they're under 5 10. you need
to ask for receipts people you think the
way This Woman's talking is if she has
everything a man wants oh men under 510
never oh God meanwhile I'm not being
funny but I've got a lot more going on
up here than you do darling you ain't
perfect a lot of people think that's
just crazy I need to do I don't think
it's that crazy also I'm 30. I'm not
really trying to just day and [__]
around the next dude I'm with I don't
even need to marry him Leo I just
want him to impregnate me she doesn't
even know how desperate she is she's
given up on the marriage she just wants
some useless thought to go and blow his
beans on my mouth I don't need you to
stick around I don't need a ring I don't
need any commitment just give me a baby
that's where you're at and you're out
here as desperate as you are acting like
five foot ten men aren't good enough for
you you should be praying for a five
foot ten man because you know what these
wealthy men that she actually aspires to
get don't one a woman who's gonna blow
all of their relationship chat all over
their podcast that's what they don't
want the maddest thing is right this
woman has loads of followers so it's not
like there's not a load of men to choose
from and yet still no ring still no baby
that should be telling you something and
if you've got a lot of money yourself
why does the guy need to have a load of
money surely you can actually just find
a nice guy because you've got enough
money anyway good luck
you gotta need it I'm not worried about
the baby imagine having this as your
mother
Jesus Christ she thinks she's got a jump
sitting chatting to this [__] fella
yeah it's a really hard job that oh
honestly work my balls off the other day
now love isn't so helpless for other
people because Kanye West has found true
love as seen here with his wife Bianca
on a boat ride in Italy
just in case you're wondering that is
actually Kanye West's ass but it wasn't
just his ass that was out his [__] was
out as well because Bianca who can't be
seen here is pleasuring him in public
just to make sure that no one recognizes
Kanye he's disguised himself very
cleverly no one will know it was me the
man's a genius I'm not Kanye West kids
but if I was I don't think I'd want to
Google that my dad and see him getting
sloppy toppy off my stepmom oh look at
that face as well she doesn't look like
she's enjoying that he doesn't even look
like he's enjoying it that much not as
good as chemist you know now we've seen
the video Kim wasn't great either and
let's not forget he met Kim Kardashian
after she'd done a sex tape and we all
knew what kind of woman she was right
treated her like a goddess loved it put
her on a pedestal dress down make her
look like a supermodel this last married
eyes like yeah get down there I think
we've got one of those things where you
know when someone breaks your heart and
then you just treat the next one like
absolute [__] that's what he's doing
right now he's just degrade in the
living life out with her and on the one
hand if she's into it fair dudes but
looking at that little face she looks
like she's just escaped the war-torn
country who I think you know you're
wanting a bit of romance Venice and he
has Kanye like yeah German on that in
conclusion Kanye West is really just a
seedy old man now only old Kanye get
your freak on son get your freak going
there is a little bit of positive news
in the world Britain's first couple
stormzy and Maya Jama are back together
lovely some of you may remember that
stormzy famously cheated on Maya Jama
and she thought I'm not accepting this
I'm going out to get me a man who
doesn't cheat congratulations stobs you
really did sure tried the rest came back
to the best baby you gotta tell stormzy
because now you know you can keep on
cheating she'll come back anyway and a
lot of you women can learn from this
right if mayajama and Beyonce can
forgive cheating then who the [__] are
you to say that you're not gonna put up
with it they're a ten you're a five and
you think you're too good to be cheated
on guess again I hope that's learned you
something from today's news they're
saying just information it's education
in other news seat belts on airplanes
are too tight for some women my seatbelt
on Orion Air flight was painfully tight
despite me being the average UK address
size oh she took a selfie didn't she she
really thought she was doing something
raising awareness now this is the woman
in question I'll let you make your own
mind up she does look like she's doing
that
foreign
says she isn't delusional about her size
but was baffled when it didn't fit she's
recently lost her Stone keep on going
tell Jim shock they'll give you a brand
deal they're always looking to look good
in public she'll be on the front page of
their Instagram next week she claims
plus size passengers might face being
judged if they have to ask cabin crew
for belt extenders you see there's just
one tiny problem for Katie I'm the 21
Stone I'm as big as a human should be
and I fit on every single airplane seat
and can belt myself up no problem so how
do you explain that Katie how do you
explain that Spanish woman's football
team have announced they will not play a
match until the Spanish president Louis
resigns which he refuses to do for those
of you don't know he grabbed the team
member of the Spanish team and planted
in non-consensual kiss on her lips at
the World Cup final it is a bit mad the
way he's grabbing a skull there it
doesn't feel consensual the issue is is
there's been uproar about this we've got
25 million views on this tweet is there
the same uproar for other instances like
this one where
this jockey gets a kiss off the owner of
the horse and um no no one cares there's
actually another one here at the
carnival this poor police officer being
sexually assaulted by this woman with a
rather large derriere and she is
grinding up and down on him but no
there's a police officer there he's the
police officer but he's not arresting
her why because he secretly loved it I
think the moral of the story here is is
that men can't force themselves on women
but women can force themselves on men
and as long as we've got that clear
we'll all be all right Lads they want
this man burned at the stake for that
kiss by the way I'm fair enough right he
shouldn't have done it but it's just
never the same energy to protect men is
it we don't need protecting we're just
Khan and father he had to provide for
women and shut the [__] up and as long
as you don't forget it Notting Hill
really is mental isn't it these women
are just shaking it all about I really
missed that Carnival should have checked
that out wow
wow do they know each other everyone's
just humping all over the shop here I
didn't realize that was sort of the
thing at Notting Hill I haven't been in
London that long I get myself down next
time they know the news Steve Harvey has
been cheated on the married man who is a
relationship expert in America gives out
a lot of advice it turns out should have
been looking indoors pal because his
wife has been [__] the help the chef
and The Bodyguard if you're wondering he
was serving up a lot more than dinner
let me tell you she ordered dick and
here she is here in the happy at times
look at that watch Jesus Steve Harvey is
Rich by the way that's mine right there
yeah I own you and you own me
I will kill everybody in here about your
ass please understand that about the way
I love you Marjorie Elaine she's been
spread like margarine uh he loved her he
really did but so did the help so what
does Steve do now well you know there's
always that girl at the start of the
video she can she can get it you know I
mean she's dirty desperate needs someone
you're rich you tick every box
essentially so this has been true news
and in the words of Forrest Gump you
never know what you're gonna get and
don't forget to subscribe like the video
come on